in terms of being a director and also
being a female director yeah what traits
are you going to take on set and i
really i resonate with what you're
talking about not being too sensitive
and not letting that affect you just you
know that's one of my hot button so what
do you think you'll take with you
because you'll be on that said it might
get high pressure it might be hot you
know the just all the variables I think
just like trying to be as like president
and attentive as possible like I had a
great teacher at NYU um IRA Sachs who
was always like the one thing he taught
me those like super important for
directing i think is like trying to
create like a very real situation and be
just observant of it and attentive and I
think sometimes you want to just
reproduce what you already planned or
had in mind so I think for me is to kind
of stay like very curious and like
present to whatever's happening and
maybe unexpected things the actors are
doing that I wasn't could have never
anticipated or you know written um so I
think that's like the main thing to just
be like excited and like attentive to
what's happening um and be very
authoritative with the children you get
along with kids but that I'm like a
little scared that it's hard to like
maintain your authority um with
ten-year-old boys I'm a little scared so
we'll see oh so don't try to be like the
cool friend yeah I gotta tend to be too
much of a friends like you gonna want
them like run off you know run all over
me or whatever I forget the word right
right